foreign
of all the planets in the universe Earth
is clearly the best for life right
wrong
Earth may be great but scientists have
discovered a few worlds that could be
even better for life
behold koi 5715.01
most of the contenders on our super
habitable planet list aren't the ones
you could visit anytime soon
they are very far away
the top spot is held by one 3
000 light years away from our solar
system
koi 575.01 would appear to satisfy the
most basic requirement for supporting
life
it exists in the Goldilocks zone of its
star
so conditions wouldn't be too hot or too
cold for a key life supporting
ingredient to exist on its surface
liquid water
but it would also check off many boxes
to be considered super habitable
the planetary system it belongs to could
be five and a half billion years old
which would make it around 1 billion
years older than our own solar system
and the planet would almost fit the size
requirement
when looking for super habitable worlds
scientists keep their eyes peeled for
planets that have a mass up to one and a
half times of our planet and they should
be about 10 percent larger too
this size difference would help the
planet retain heat and if its average
temperature was about 5 degrees Celsius
higher than Earth's well this planet
could have even richer biodiversity
now being almost double the size of
Earth koi 571 5.01 might overshoot this
condition a bit
besides studies indicate that this
planet is actually colder than Earth
but there's still hope with the right
atmospheric composition a strong
greenhouse effect could raise
temperatures to the desired level and as
far as super habitable worlds go well
we're just getting started
when it comes to making this planet
habitable at this time of year we fall
back on what makes us and others feel
better shopping you know holiday
shopping may give you a rush but it can
also sustain the corporate world's
Stranglehold on small businesses
how do they do that well when you shop
online like on Amazon or Walmart well
these companies use their sales
platforms to promote their products over
smaller businesses with competing
products unfairly this practice is
called self-preferencing because it puts
the company's interests ahead of
anything or anyone else so how can you
help well buy locally you know small
business owners account for more than 64
percent of new jobs in the United States
so work for the anti-monopoly shift
power away from major corporations and
help provide more opportunities for your
community keeping each other fed and our
community is thriving that's how we make
a planet habitable
approximately 2 700 light years away is
Kepler 69c
this super Earth could be around 7
billion years old
this puts it perfectly in the estimated
five to eight billion year old age range
for super habitable planets this range
is based on the three and a half billion
years it took for a complex life to
appear on Earth
so the best chance for finding life
could be on a planet a little older than
us
only this exoplanet could be a little
too big to be super habitable it has a
mass almost four times that of Earth
a rocky planet this big could have a
single colossal continent that would
have huge deserts in its Center
but the coastline Washed by Kepler's
ocean could be your perfect spot to move
to
our next Super Earth shares a similar
name Kepler 1126b except it would be
located ever so slightly closer to home
yeah this planet is about
2073 light years away and it belongs to
a system that is seven and a half
billion years old
it also orbits a yellow dwarf star much
like our own
only Kepler 1126b is two and a half
times closer to its star than Earth is
to the Sun
but that's no big deal because the star
Kepler 1126b orbits is cooler than ours
so the habitable zone would exist in a
Range much closer in proximity to it
if you aren't feeling this nearness to a
scorching hot star there's another Super
Earth on our list and it's at a
reasonable distance from home
speculos 2C is located only 106 light
years away
not that its proximity gives it any kind
of advantage
it would still take you well over 200
000 years to travel to this super Earth
and that's if you moved at the speed of
NASA's Parker solar probe the fastest
probe ever launched
speculos 2C does look promising though
it's about 40 percent larger than Earth
there's also the potential for it being
a rocky planet just like ours
now despite the fact that it also exists
in a habitable zone it's red dwarf star
is still very small it's only about 15
percent the size of our sun
so this planet orbits around its star at
a very close distance
and this close distance could mean that
speculos 2C is tidally locked to its
star
this super Earth takes eight and a half
days to make one full rotation on its
axis as well as one orbit around its
star
that would leave one side of the planet
in constant daylight and the other in
Endless Night
this means that life could be possible
in The Terminator Zone
the thin strip of land between the two
sides we just need to get a better look
to find out for sure
but with all these candidates so far
away wouldn't it be nicer if the planets
in our own solar system were a little
more habitable
well that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]